in one of these situations that's
that might sometimes be a free library
and exchange library on a street corner
i found
this poem this week and i'm going to uh
now no i've i've got
a different picture here when this is
over it's called by someone named laura
kelly fannucci when this is over
may we never again take for granted a
handshake with a stranger
full shelves at the store conversations
with neighbors
a crowded theater friday night out
the taste of communion a routine checkup
the school rush each morning coffee with
a friend
the stadium roaring each deep breath
a boring tuesday life itself
when this ends may we find that we have
become more like the people we wanted to
be
we were called to be we hoped to be and
may we stay that way
better for each other because of the
worst
that's a really good poem yeah yeah and
i was struck by it when i ran into it
delightful that you found it outside
indeed yeah i was out getting a little
brisk walking outside and i found that
poem yeah that's great that's great
yeah yeah i have the sense the person
who wrote that is a wise person
indian um be cool to figure out who they
are yeah
well if anyone uh here in portland knows
knows
her tell her we talked about her
and consider getting in touch
you